what was it about the talk show
form or genre that felt like kind of an
ideal
vessel for what you wanted to do uh it's
the oldest format on television one of
the oldest formats in television
and it's um it's both
very structured but it's very easy to
deviate from the structure when
necessary
so you so it's it leaves room for a
tangent
um and i don't know i just like all my
influences were
like mock talk shows like it's
like it's not making fun of talk shows
it's celebrating mock talk shows so tom
green show jiminy glick space ghost
dolly g show those are like my biggest
influences those were the shows that
made me laugh the hardest
yeah have you ever like talked shop with
any of those people like
yeah yeah i've been into i've been to
sasha's house i've been to tom
tom green's house you know those guys
are
sweetie guys those are the they're like
my forefathers mike lazzo
who invented who created space ghosts
you know with keith crawford they they
run
i mean lazaro just retired but they you
know run adult swim
so obviously i've been working with them
intimately for like a decade
um yeah never been martin short but i've
got to work with most of my heroes it's
pretty cool
that's incredible um so each season of
the show has
you ha you have kind of a wildly
different body transformation look
the production design shifts what was
sort of the
process behind season fives look well i
just wrote down
i didn't know how i was gonna look i
just wrote down i was like what would it
be what would i look like if i did the
opposite of everything i did the
previous season
so the previous season season four i
lost weight i got
pale i put i grew up my fingernails i
never brushed or washed my hair i grew
up my hair i get this ratty cheek hair
that comes in
i didn't wear deodorant i didn't wash
the suit once
um i looked like really ratty and like
kind of like a prisoner
like in like a north korea detention
center
season five i did everything the
opposite i gained weight
i got really tan i bleached my teeth i
not only wore deodorant but i wore a ton
of brute cologne
i got rid of all my body hair including
my pubic hair i waxed i narrowed my legs
i shaved my armpits i picked my head
bald the only hair i kept for my
eyebrows
um and uh
yeah i looked like uh vin diesel
six weeks after he died
post-mortem than diesel uh what does it
do to your
guests the kind of like visceral the
scent based sort of stuff can you
do you see like it [ __ ] with them in a
certain way yeah i think so if somebody
like you don't know very well gives you
a big hug
and they either smell like rancid body
odor or they smell like a ton of
cheap kmart cologne you're gonna have a
reaction you're gonna be like i'm
dealing with like
a different type of person yeah and what
is kind of the
what is the difference between having a
guest on the show who maybe doesn't know
what they're in for
versus someone who is at least passingly
familiar with what
you tend to do to the guests well we
always aim for the guest that
doesn't even know my name who's just
looking for
screen time that's the best but if they
do know me
it doesn't matter we got to show down to
the science where it doesn't matter how
well they know me or the show if
you know cockroaches are exploding out
of the desks and
you know my clothes are falling off and
stunt men are falling from the sky
they're going to have a reaction so
why torture america's sweetheart judy
greer
you know what judy greer was the best
yeah the best she was so sweet she came
on
she we got her i think she's i think
she's a fan of the show
but she was so overwhelmed
but you know it's never mean-spirited
there's never malicious intent because
it's not
fun or funny it's not fun for me you
know i'm a
benevolent terrorist so i'm just i'm
just doing it to
blow people's minds and cram and
absurdity into reality and
distort the truth i'm never looking to
hurt anyone's feelings
where you headed i'm gonna like eat nice
what are you having
uh pickled vegetables and some rice
who's that on your shirt
lisa gayle uh why do i know that name
who is that
he sings the three second rule yes
thank you i love that yes thank you yes
he's awesome
um so benevolent terrorist
that chorus is objectively good i gotta
say yeah i like that song
the benevolent terrorist idea does that
apply to when you do the more like
random man on the street hidden camera
stuff or are you kind of like
yeah i'm a benevolent terrorist there as
well
how do you how do you kind of harm
anybody or hurt anybody's feelings
i'm looking to blow people's minds and
have a
bizarre um
distort somebody's reality so how do you
react when people kind of have a
what seems to me like an emotionally
volatile sort of reaction
you know um i'll be honest with you the
people that are
seem the most angry when we cut and we
go
surprise you're in a hidden camera show
there's the cameras
they're the most they tend to be the
most relieved and the most happy
and those are the people that laugh the
hardest after the
the prank is revealed and we have to get
the release for
nine times out of ten it's usually like
the soccer moms and the karen's that
have this like quiet
like stewing brewing anger yes
eating anger that are
they don't give the best reaction to be
aren't too happy after the prank
so so usually those really volatile
people are like so relieved
that it's a prank show that they're like
oh yeah you know
that's like you know you gotta you gotta
crack a few eggs to make an omelet
that you do um speaking of crack and
eggs
you the art of your obliteration of your
set
each episode is really something i
marvel at especially in this new season
technically stunt wise how do you plan
these sequences and execute these
sequences
um just like we play on any any other
part of the show
you know it's case by case what what
needs to get done but now we got to show
down to a science we know it's like
producible and not producible so like
when you
tackle the drummer of your new band
through the wall yeah is that like you
you're like landing on a pad
you have a stunt performer you're
working with what is that like i used to
i used to not use any pads not use stunt
people
i would like wipe out on the concrete
and pledge my body now we have like a
stun coordinator and i kind of like
do it the proper way because i was like
putting myself in the hospital every
time
i still went to the hospital this year
what for
john cena threw me through a shelf
which is fine he did the stun properly
but then after the stunt
the shelf fell over and the
frame of the shelf which was metal
clocked me in the head
geez louise so we no fault of john
cena's it was
more my art department's fault
uh so john cena's on this the episodes
i've seen we have like
anderson pock machine gun kelly lamorin
morris
you seem to have a way to get these
folks to come and clown for like just
one bit
or one line even macaulay falcon with
the chainsaw
what do you think it is that like
appeals to these people to come play for
a second
i mean now we have fans of the show like
macaulay copeland's like a super fam
yeah so it makes it easier to book
um it's a quarter-hour show you got to
keep it moving like
i can only cram so many jokes and i
don't i'm not stretching for time
you know i was curious about that it is
such
like a relentlessly paced show yeah when
you're
when you're shooting it does it feel
that quickly moving or is it more
yeah what yeah every interview is like
an hour
wow and you know setting up a hidden
camera
setup is very tedious you know hidden
camera means hitting crew so it's like
really
cumbersome like it's already very slow
shooting something scripted if it was a
script to show so imagine like
all the like tedious measures the
scripted
crew goes through times 10 because then
you have to like
hide the crew and
like seduce an unsuspecting pedestrian
into the kill zone
and then like you know blow their mind
you know it's very very very slow moving
yeah um and the editing process
is you know tedious too i was wondering
about the editing this
it feels very you know it's obviously
frenetic and it's prone to like
the moment that really tickled me was
like that when the everyone starts
singing that kind of like weird
christian song
abruptly and you like put someone else's
face on someone
are you in the editing room often kind
of wait what which bit is that
there's this thing in like the first
episode of the new season where
randomly someone would start singing
like i will praise you or something like
that
is it in the studio or in the street
street
oh in the street what street bit is that
i don't know it it was a post gag you
like added it in
editing i can't remember what the bid is
though what
what the prep what's what's the premise
of the segment do you remember not on
top of your head
um maybe it was
[ __ ] with the uh city surveyor
oh oh praise to the lord yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah yeah are you in the editing room
like pitching yeah
it's a it's a group effort it's like all
my editors my director
and i uh yeah i'm in there
all when we're in post-production i'm in
the editing video all day every day
yeah bouncing around we have a team of
editors bouncing around
and we'll have like friends and family
screenings to see what's actually
funny and not working or confusing or
needs clarity
like it is a
slow and steady process yeah is there
anything
through this kind of slow cutting down
to the diamonds
stuff that you've lost that you're
particularly like god i wish we could
have kept that in
um there's always like yeah there there
are there are always those moments but
uh
you know you gotta kill darlings
that's like part of the process yeah you
know if it's something that like i
had to cut for time but it's killing me
i can always like throw it up online or
do like a extended dance remix cup you
know
oh hell yeah um is there anything that
made it into this season that you
were either like there's no way we can
pull this off or adult zoom was like are
you sure you want to do this
anything you're surprised made it to the
final cut no not really i think like
there's some pranks that i'm so happy we
pulled off
so well like we did this prank where i
like there was
we're like on a construction site right
on the east river
in brooklyn and there was this
construction worker doing construction
and i came out of the water dressed like
a mafia guy with cement bricks
on my feet and i was like dragging like
dragging myself at the water i was like
help help me
i was like and this construction worker
was totally on the hook he's like what
the [ __ ] going on man
i was like i got mixed up with the wrong
crowd these guys threw me off a boat
they put me in cement shoes and threw me
off a boat last night
and he's like oh my god you look [ __ ]
up and he was like
so on the hook for this ridiculous mafia
premise
that like i think it's our greatest
uh greatest prank achievement
i can't wait to see that yeah with these
random folks on the street
do you try to engage with them the way
that like an improv comedian would
engage with the scene partner are they
like a sparring partner or are you
trying to just kind of
do your thing to them so to speak um
yeah i'm just trying to get them to
react to the situation and believe the
situation
that's what it's it's about like buying
into the
like surreal you know
situation and then like reacting and
being like
on the hook and being invested in it you
know yeah
so that's that's the that's the key um
what does it feel like to be so memed
from this show some so many elements of
this have become
memes that are passed around is that
weird or surreal no that's awesome those
memes kept the momentum alive between
season four and season five because i
had to take so much time off to make the
movie
the movie didn't come out because of
corona it's coming out next year
so the memes
you know i and i that i can't even take
credit for kept the momentum
build the fan base of the show kept the
momentum alive i like
you know i was selling out
theaters and and the largest venues i've
ever performed at
on this tour i did last fall and i
hadn't even been on the air for three
and a half years four years
so to me like i don't know it was all
the memes but the memes kept hope alive
kept the momentum it's pretty incredible
as they do for all of us
you're referring to bad trip the movie
you shot yeah i was curious
when what what what are the plans for us
being able to see that thing
yeah it's coming out on netflix so we uh
you know we're going to premiere at
south by southwest this year we're going
to be in theaters everywhere this year
and then corona happened like a week
before south by southwest it was
devastating
but then netflix saw the movie and loved
it and bought it off
mgm so it's gonna come out next year on
netflix um
i probably can't say that i'm probably
not allowed to say the date yet but um
uh thank god it's on netflix because
netflix is
like there's no greater venue
than a streaming service that has 200
million
subscriptions i think they went from
like 118 million subscribers to like 200
million subscribers in like
six months of quarantine so we're kind
of at the best
you know venue in town um
thank god so and they're really excited
about the movie so unfortunately we have
to wait
even longer for it to come out but when
it comes out it's going to be
glorious i can't wait were there any
kind of
key differences or expansions with
like producing man on the street hidden
camera stuff for tv
versus film film was even harder
not because of like the production setup
but like
each scene in the film it's a narrative
film so each scene in the film
required the story to progress
more and more so we're looking for plot
points from real people so not only are
we pranking people
but we're like trying to pull plot
points
out of them to motivate our characters
you know it was me little rel
howery and tiffany haddish you know
we're
trying to like pull plot out of people
as we're [ __ ] with them which is like
an extra step of you know
difficulty so it was uh it was
definitely a new challenge
yeah what were uh lil rel and tiffany
like to be kind of your partners in
crime had they done this kind of stuff
before
tiffany had rel never had it rel [ __ ]
hated it he was like this is so
stressful he's like this is so [ __ ]
stressful he was like having
he was good at it you know the crime was
like i was like you're [ __ ] good at
it like when he's in its own
once you call action he would do it but
he hated it tiffany had done it before
and she um
she's just like the funniest person on
earth i mean she's like comedy on a
cellular level and there's no medium of
comedy that she can't do
getting camera pranks stand up acting
like writing whatever anything you need
her to do
she there's a reason she's a movie star
you know what i mean she's truly like
just [ __ ] incredible yes she is um
speaking of
other avenues of comedy i'm really
intrigued by connected
which you do a voice in oh yeah what was
it like
what's it like being a voice actor
versus kind of a on-screen performer
i love it because you can be so hyped up
and animated you don't have to
like internalize your emotions in fact
you want to like
you really want to take it to the nines
because it gives the animator something
to animate and
we only hear the voice we don't see the
face so
uh live action acting is difficult
because you have to be
very emotional but internalize it this
you can just go to the moon and i'm
already a human cartoon you know so
it's a perfect perfect life for me what
was kind of the most
fun or exciting uh a bit or gag you did
in connected that you're just like
jazzed for folks to see
i like deep throat at a burrito
hell yeah
hell yeah
was it um speaking of voice acting was
it
surreal to get the call to be in
the disney live-action lion king what
what was it yeah you know my my reaction
was more surreal somebody called me like
hey dude i had a mole on the inside a
friend that like worked there she was
like hey
you're gonna make you an offer for the
lion king i just wanted to let you know
congrats
and i was so busy with work i think i
was working on bad trip at the time
trying to finish it
that i was like uh lion king i probably
can't do that i think i'm busy
and my agent was like dude it's the
[ __ ] lion king you gotta do it what
do you say
what are you thinking i was like oh yeah
yeah
uh so it was great i got to meet beyonce
what's she like she's very nice
what did y'all what do you talk about
with beyonce it was regal i mean
i said hi nice to meet you that was the
beginning and end of the conversation
yeah you know that's i'm glad to hear
she's nice
um she's nice to me uh
so collider the outlet i'm interviewing
you for it we're a huge
pop star fans oh nice i
just cackle at the cmz
scenes what was it like setting up and
playing in those scenes were those
mostly improvised or did you have free
rainbows yeah they were they were they
were scripted but
like improvisation heavily encouraged
and and it was like you know it's the
lonely island guys
and bigly uh chelsea will arnett
you know what i mean it's people that
are like great comedic minds so like
i think the majority of the final cut
was like heavily improvised stuff
you know so it was great because we
could just go to the [ __ ] moon
and yeah we learned that's so funny
chelsea and berbeglie are so funny
they're you know i was like padded
i would i was like comfortable because i
was like padded with very very funny
people i didn't have to like
work so hard yeah it makes the job
easier um
the way i think i first was introduced
to you as a comedy voice was on your
role
on don't trust the bee in apartment 23.
and you've also done you had like a
recurring role on two broke girls
kind of a piece of a more traditional
narrative network sitcom versus what
you're doing now
what what does it feel like that says
about where your career is going what
are some of the differences there
um don't just be in apartment 23 i like
because it had like a
30 rock kind of comedic sensibility
um and i really like natachika khan who
created it
um and also i was flat broke when i
booked it
so part of it was like survival yeah
uh two broke girls i always felt like i
had to
like prove i could do a traditional
comedy
i don't know why i felt like i needed to
do that or who i needed to do that for
i felt like i was like well miles davis
had to put out kind of blue before he
like switched to fusion
but looking back on that i didn't need
you know i mean some stuff i did like
some of those multi-camp sitcoms i did
even like guest stars and stuff like
that would just have a necessity because
i was broke
but i don't think i did i'm not like an
actor for hire i think i want to like
only be in stuff that i'm i participate
in the writing
of you know what i mean yeah yeah that
makes sense um shifting back to
your show uh the dynamic between you and
hannibal burr is the on-screen dynamic
are those
in any way planned in the writer's room
or is he just kind of
reacting no i don't think hannibal has
ever
read a script for the eric andrew showed
his life
uh he just comes on and it's honestly
it's better that way it's almost
his process and
we've just known each other for 10 15
years you know what i mean so we have a
comfort and he was there from the very
very beginning of the show he's always
opposed so
uh yeah that's heavily improvised i will
give him little
hand props and suggestions stuff he can
play with you know
i do want to ask about the inception of
maybe my favorite bit from your whole
show the one i keep
rewatching uh his morpheus rap
oh yeah it's just such sublime nonsense
yeah
where did that come from what was it
like to people it was like we were in
the writers room and we were like trying
to squeeze out ideas and like
either ketau or like we pitched it as
like a
exhausted end of the day kind of idea i
was like
i thought i pitched it but guitar swears
that he bitched it was one of us going
like
uh uh what if hannibal comes on he's
just like morpheus said he just says
morpheus
morpheus like purposely bad idea
we're dying because it was such a bad
idea and then we pitched it to hannibal
or we just like put him in that outfit
he did one take and he was like
what is this bit like you just rhyme the
word morpheus dresses morpheus
and then he was like that's it and i was
like that is it i was like okay so
the majority of that is his second take
and then he just like
he was like i'm gonna [ __ ] nail this
any opportunity he has to wrap he
takes it where did the uh the button on
that the coffin
and the 40 how did that uh get thrown in
there
uh i think i wrote in the script like he
drinks a 40 in a coffin and then like he
came up with the line
morpheus drinking a 40 and a damn basket
he's [ __ ] nuts wild
um a couple more questions for you is
there
i know we just finished and we're about
to see season five is there are there
talks about
season six of the eric andre show
yeah i mean you have to ask the network
if it's up to me
yeah first please but i think like the
fifth season probably has to air first
before that
order yeah makes sense to me yeah
uh final question for you kind of a
broad one
watching especially this new season
what does it take these days to be like
absurd or all of these words are in
quotes absurd
shocking transgressive disruptive i feel
like we've seen
so much weird [ __ ] not only as comedy
consumers but just as people in this
weird
[ __ ] up time what's kind of your
strategy for
cutting through all that noise uh
i think like instead of academically
being like i must be absurd you just
have to like
be authentic and authentic to yourself
and if something doesn't feel authentic
don't do it i think people respond to
authenticity
yeah simple i love that awesome thanks
so much for your time eric this is yeah
thanks
thank you nice to meet you